[Music]
when i perform this
transform i has to perform
as a woman for me
preserving
tradition is important because
the tradition is
identity of the country
[Music]
cross gender dancing is when the roles
of both the female and male are played
by one man using costumes masks and
movement the dancers are able to easily
transition between the two gendered
characters they are playing
my name is titi ninitawa
i am a cross-gender dancer from
indonesia
in the past males would play female
roles in performances and plays and
although women are now allowed to
perform through those old rules this new
dance was born
i learned when i
very very very young
since i was kid
i liked dressing up as a woman
then actually i realized that
a lot of cancer in indonesia they have
kind of this talent
this means a lot actually the meal want
to be a female dancer
[Music]
the dance moves themselves are mostly
traditional indonesian styles diric
takes time perfecting female movement so
his transitions can appear as authentic
as possible
i think
it took about 20 years
the reaction of the audience it depends
on the performance people sometimes
bullying
if
the
maintaining is the moon is like break
sometimes also in the beginning i feel
hurt and then i feel too sad i just
ignore the criticism
and i just go on and i deflate and i
prove to the society that i can do this
kind of transform
the best
today deedic travels the world teaching
people about this form of dance
preserving the culture and tradition for
future generations
and in doing so he is making a
difference in erasing the stigmas the
dance has faced i wish
that society
more understand
from where this traditional of cross
gender transform came from
and
what the history
and what the purpose
of this performance then say it more
[Music]